and here at the arm here the guts the
question in case you're too lazy to fine
for the question is on your sheet they
give you this polynomial they say it has
such-and-such zeros okay so the first
thing you're gonna work out is okay this
B C and B these coefficients alright
they're very 200 somebody can we work
out what B C and D are now there's two
ways to go about this okay number one
well you tell me what what's what's the
first way that jumps out to your mind
and how are you gonna solve for B C and
D what would you do to work them now
yeah good so we would use just as we've
been discussing well the special version
of the remain with you the factor
theorem because if there are zeros here
right that means that when you divide by
X so when you divide by X minus three or
when you divide by X plus three you were
to get no remainder
so when you sub in P of 0 you'll get 0
7 p3 at 0 7 P of minus 3 you get 0 and
then you can store some total you get
three questions there's the first thing
that your about it but there's kind of a
quicker way because of this specific
kind of question right because um what
does it mean for it to have zeros here
like well it means that there are
factors that correspond to those zeros
so if the zero is zero okay the fact
that the corresponds to that is X yes if
there's a factor sorry there's a zero of
3 then the factor that corresponds to
that is X minus 3 and likewise for the
zero of minus 3 it corresponds to the
factor X plus 3 okay now the reason why
I can do this is because I already know
it's morning
okay there are only going to be three
factors because it's a cubic right so I
can go ahead and expand that and you'll
get an X cubed minus okay so therefore
in this particular case it looks like B
is 0 D is 0 and C is minus 9 you can go
ahead and verify that that's not
actually the interesting part of the
question I want to get from that to the
next bit let's graph it
now because they already told us what
the zeros are right and it's a cubed you
can actually know with some confidence
what its gonna look like if there are
zero is that -3 0 & 3 okay now this is a
cubic right so it's gonna have this
wiggle thing but I have a question for
you how do you know whether it's this
kind of wiggle well that kind of wiggle
yeah good you look at this is why we
introduced all this language right you
look at the leading coefficient and it's
positive right well actually it's
positive from over there okay
so therefore as X tends to infinity a
positive coefficient means that Y also
tends to infinity okay so you're gonna
get this graph okay so far so good right
now there's my graph but here's where it
starts to get kind of the last part the
question is not just solved but heads
solve this inequality okay
now when I look to this equality I was
like what does this have to do with
anything right have a look at what we've
got here yeah we'll get there but that's
that's not as intuitive in my sound and
there problems with it as well you've
got this okay so I could solve this
quite easily that's pretty easy to solve
off the graph right namely where is this
thing positive so just looking at it
it's positive between here and here
right so I'm destroying it like a normal
line solution right I'm not including
the boundaries because that batteries
not included and also it's positive okay
so there's that but what does that have
to do with this okay
well two things firstly you could do
what Jessi suggested which is divide
both sides by x squared
I could kind of sort off okay basically
right I'm converting to something which
will be actually useful now the reason
why I divided by x squared is sort of a
good idea is because x squared is almost
always positive right so that means I
don't have to muck around with which
direction you get equality so we'll go
in okay
so sure enough this is x squared minus 9
on X and that's still 0 the reason why
it's you gotta be careful is because
well what about x equals 0 okay now the
reason why in this case that actually
happens to not be a problem is because
it's a non-inclusive boundary right so X
can't equal okay but it's more dangerous
because sometimes X can be equal to 0 so
you've got to be really careful with
dividing by things like that okay make a
better way to think about it is like so
what I solve this inequality right is
really this inequality okay now remember
think back to further graphs and Marcos
when we were trying to do like the side
of a graph and we're trying to shave to
see where it went through when we had
like rational functions that kind of
thing so we would say look sure this
factor line then draw you know these two
factor lines X plus 3 X minus 3
okay you draw them through and that's
where you know what positive or negative
okay but can you see that this part is
the same in both questions but what's
different is that this is actually 1
over X right so being that these two
parts are the same I'm just going to
stop worrying about them for a second
now when you look at the X and the 1
over X can you see that when this is
positive this is also positive right and
when this is negative this is also
negative so therefore since as factors
being positive or negative they behave
in exactly the same way solving these
two inequalities will give me exactly
the same result they are equivalent in
the qualities okay so so therefore this
answer that we got right for this
inequality is the same answer as for
this ok so the actual answer
- three - zero or greater than three
it's the same now just to prove it to
you okay what does this inequality
actually looks like well if you graph it
it's pretty simple rather quickly
it's got a vertical asymptote where zero
it's got the Bleak asymptote where y
equals x it actually goes through the
origin
okay then when you solve it to find your
intercepts surprise surprise your
intercepts are minus 3 and 3 so what
does this one look like it looks like
this now if we're solving for when it's
greater than 0 to the right of here but
I can't go past there because there's an
asymptote and then over here well from Y
to the right which is exactly the same
okay so you can see not just
algebraically but geometric